well you know it's funny actually wait
as i think about the candidates i might
actually wait am i the oldest player in
the field
it's like i actually am right i've never
thought about that until now oh my gosh
that's crazy
[Music]
hikaru
hardy hardy hardy congratulations on
qualifying for the candidates
uh brilliant you know when you make us
all so very very proud uh well done my
friend well done thank you thank you
appreciate it yeah i mean i just do what
i can
well you certainly did and to get to the
candidates
as everybody knows it's really really
hard but now you got that next mountain
which is
you
there's one prize right i mean you got
to be a challenger how are you preparing
yourself
yeah i mean at the moment it's first of
all trying to assemble team obviously
unlike when i qualified in 2016 or
frankly i think unlike any cycle in
recent memory i mean for obvious reasons
of course uh the final two qualifiers
both myself and richard report uh we
have very limited time it's only two
months before the event starts and so
first things first i'm basically trying
to put together the team and then
probably in a week or so i'll start
start looking at ideas just in depth i
mean i guess technically we still don't
even know who the eighth player is
although of course it's going to be ding
lauren um so
yeah probably about a week i'll start
looking at stuff but it's just great to
qualify i think for me
more than qualifying even was the fact
that i was able to put together a great
run at the end at the end of the event
in berlin winning those three games in a
row in the qualifying stage and i mean
obviously after that it's all kind of
just gravy basically
absolutely becoming the number one
ranked player in blitz the number one
ranked player in rapid uh it's all all
very good and you see that that's a kind
of an interesting thing and i think a
lot of people in the audiences
uh
would like your insights you say you're
putting together a team you're working
to put together a team what does that
mean what
what what does a candidate
grandmaster like yourself what what is a
team
yeah so i i i think first and foremost
um well you look at a game like i played
against levon this this sort of stuff
where someone has an idea i made it work
in this rapid game if this was a
classical game i suspect that after this
whole g5 thing i would have been in
trouble so what you do is you try to
pick one or two people to help you out
with preparation and very specific
openings which is also why you generally
don't reveal who you're working with
until after the event because people
know ahead of time there's certain
players who play certain openings you
just don't want them having that
information um so mainly just looking at
players who are specialists in certain
openings maybe they have some special
skill like you can play training games
against them maybe you play the rui
lopez very well maybe they play
something like queen's game declined but
generally you're just looking for those
sorts of things and people who are
experts in their field although i do
have to say
uh in all fairness i kind of did that in
2016 where i where i worked with peter
lecko and i decided to play the queen's
indian defense and uh two of my three
losses in that event were in the queen's
indian defense so it can be a
double-edged sword
exactly
hikari i just had one quick question
about your sort of mental preparation
for the event um are you sort of trying
to treat it like you know like the grand
prix and telling yourself this is just
another tournament and i got to play my
best or is it for you just sort of this
is a special tournament and your mental
preparation is sort of very specific how
are you
coaching yourself mentally in
preparation for the candidates yeah i
mean i think for me i treat it mostly
it's just another tournament but one
thing um that i've said quite a bit
recently is that perhaps my two my two
biggest regrets both come from the
candidates in 2016 first of all
switching my openings playing this
queen's indian defense instead of
playing the queen's game declined at the
time which i did play later in the event
and won a game against topalov with um
but that was one of them but the second
thing with the candidates in 2016 was
that i felt that i just basically
cracked under pressure i think every
night of sleeping maybe four or five
hours and i just let all that stress and
pressure get to me and even if i don't
win the tournament this time i think
just having that chance to try and play
good chess and and perform better than i
did just on that level is is probably
for me um the the most important thing
um because i really didn't think i would
ever have that chance after 2016.
it sounds like you've already taken a
lot of lessons from your very first
candidate experience and now you
understand
yourself
just a lot better as a player
you're a much more mature player now
hikaru how do you rate your chances
well i mean i i to to be fair i'm quite
fortunate i think that if this is a 2019
for example i would probably have the
same issues with stress and pressure i
think if you look at say levon aronia
being the most prominent example i and
he played five or six candidates and
every single time after the first half
he was leading and then towards then
something went wrong i think the fact
that it's not make or break for me the
way that it will be for pretty much
every other player uh definitely helps
me and i think you know i would say this
if i get out of the openings and i'm not
in a lot of trouble i think i'm maybe
maybe even a favorite in the event or at
least i feel very confident about my
chances to just play chess
wow oh thank you carl we'll let you
we'll let you go back to your stream one
last very very quick question are you
excited to play alireza for russia and
the candidates um are you excited to
show that the older generation still has
some miles left in the tank well you
know it's funny actually wait as i think
about the candidates i might actually
wait am i the oldest player in the field
[Laughter]
i actually am right i've never thought
about that until now oh my gosh that's
crazy um
you're the old man in the field
that's insane um
it's a young man's game
yeah so i think what i would say is uh i
mean for playing ollie rezzy's probably
one player that i haven't played a lot
obviously he's been training for a long
time for the candidates um so it's going
to be exciting i think for ali reza
obviously there are a lot of people who
have really high expectations thinking
he's going to win the tournament um
playing magnus in the future but for me
i just i i feel like i've always done
well against him and it's going to be
very exciting to play against someone
who's so much younger than i am because
really since maybe the time it played
against magnus i haven't felt i mean
when magnus first verse on the scene i
don't feel like i've played someone
where i felt that they're really all
that much younger than me it's just a
couple of years give or take um so it's
gonna be it's going to be exciting and i
mean we'll we'll see how it goes
wonderful hey carl what can i say we
wish you our absolute best of luck and
uh we'll be applauding and cheering you
on in your campaign to become challenger
thank you so much you guys
[Music]
you